[Music]
the cry of the crowd the roar of a lion
the clash of metal starting in a TCE
the sound rang through the stands of the
Colosseum on hundreds of days a year
over 50,000 residents of Rome and
visitors from across the Roman Empire
would fill the stadiums for stories to
see gladiators duel animals fight in
chariots race around the arena and for
the grand finale water poured into the
arena basin submerging the stage for the
greatest spectacle of all staged naval
battles the Romans epic mock maritime
encounters called no machi I started
during Julius Caesar's reign in the
first century BC over a hundred years
before the Colosseum was built they were
held alongside other aquatic spectacles
on natural and artificial bodies of
water around Rome up through Emperor
Flavius for spacian who began building
the Colosseum in 70 CE II on the site of
a former lake the Colosseum was intended
to be a symbol of Rome's power in the
ancient world and what better way to
display that power than a body of water
that could drain and refill at the
Emperor's command force patience son
Flavius Titus fulfilled his father's
dream in a TCE when he used war spoils
to finish the Colosseum or as it was
known at the time the Flavian
amphitheater the grand opening was
celebrated with 100 days of pageantry
and gladiatorial games setting the
precedent for programming that included
parades musical performances public
executions and of course gladiatorial
combat unlike the games and smaller
amphitheaters funded by wealthy Romans
these lavish displays of imperial power
were financed by the Emperor parades of
exotic animals theatrical performances
and the awe-inspiring no machi I were
all designed to bolster faith in the
godlike emperor who would be declared a
god after his own death
it's still a mystery how engineers
flooded the arena to create this aquatic
effect some historians believe a giant
aqueduct was diverted into the arena
others think the system of chambers and
sluice gates used to drain the arena
were also used to fill it these chambers
could have been filled with water prior
to the event and then opened to submerge
the stage under more than a million
gallons of water to create a depth of
five feet but even with all that water
the Romans had to construct miniature
boat with special flat bottoms that
wouldn't scrape the Colosseum floor
these boats range from 7 to 15 metres
long and were built to look like vessels
from famous encounters during a battle
dozens of these ships would float around
the arena crewed by gladiators dressed
as the opposing sides of the recreated
battle these Warriors would duel across
ships boarding them fighting drowning
and incapacitating their foes until only
one faction was left standing
fortunately not every watery display
told such a gruesome story in some of
these floodings
a submerged stage allowed chariot
drivers to glide across the water
as though they were Triton making waves
as he piloted his chariot on the sea
animals walked on water myths were
reenacted by condemned prisoners and at
night nude synchronized swimmers would
perform by torchlight but the
Colosseum's aquatic age didn't last
forever the naval battles proved so
popular they were given their own nearby
lake by emperor Domitian in the early
90s seee the larger lake proved even
better for no maki I and the Coliseum
soon gained a series of underground
animal cages and trapdoors that didn't
allow for further flooding but for a
brief time the Flavian Emperor's
controlled the tides of war and water in
a spectacular show of power want to
learn more about the history and science
behind some of your favorite sports step
up your game with this playlist
[Music]